in the previous video we explored how
the cosine and sines of angles relate
when we essentially take the terminal
ray of the angle and we reflect it about
the x or the y axis or both axes what i
want to do in this video is think a
little bit about the tangent of these
different angles so just as a little bit
of a reminder we know that the tangent
of theta is equal to the sine
of an angle over the cosine of an angle
and by the unit circle definition it's
essentially saying what is the slope of
the terminal ray right over here if you
we remind ourselves slope slope is rise
over run it is our change in the
vertical axis over our change in the
horizontal axis if we're starting at the
origin what is our change in the
vertical axis if we go from zero to sine
theta well we're our change in the
vertical axis is sine theta what is our
change in the horizontal axis it's
cosine of theta so this is change in y
over change in x for the terminal ray
terminal
terminal i'll just write terminal
for the terminal ray so the tangent of
theta is the sine of theta over cosine
theta or you could view it as the slope
of this ray right over here
so let's think about what other what
other angles are going to have the exact
same tangent of theta
well this ray is collinear with this
array right over here in fact if you
kind of put them together you get a line
so the tangent of this angle right over
here this pink angle going all the way
around the tangent of pi plus theta or
the tangent
of theta plus pi
i'm just obviously you could write theta
plus pi instead of dot pi plus theta
this should be just based on this kind
of slope argument this should be equal
to the tangent of theta
this should be equal to the tangent of
theta let's see if this actually is the
case
so these two things should be equal if
we agree that the tangent of an angle is
equal to the slope of the terminal the
slope of the terminal ray of course the
other side of the angle is is going to
be the positive x-axis based on the
conventions that we've set up
well let's look let's think about what
it is what the tangent of thot
of theta plus pi is in terms of sine and
cosine
so the tangent
let me write this down in that pink
color
the tangent that's not pink
the
tangent
of
pi plus theta that's going to be equal
to put the parentheses to avoid
ambiguity that's equal to the sine of pi
plus theta
of our theta plus pi
over the cosine of theta plus pi
and in the previous video we established
that the sine of of theta plus pi
that's the same thing as negative sine
theta so this is equal to negative sine
theta and the cosine of theta plus pi we
already established that's the same
thing as negative cosine of theta
negative cosine of theta well you have a
negative divided by negative you can say
the negatives cancel out and we're left
with sine theta over cosine theta which
is indeed tangent of theta so we could
feel pretty good about that
now what about
what about this
what about the points or the terminal
rays
right over here
so let's think about this point what is
the tangent
what is the tangent of negative theta
going to be
well we know that the tangent of
negative theta is the same thing as the
sine of negative theta over the cosine
of negative theta and we already
established we already established the
sine of negative theta
that's negative sine theta
that's negative sine theta we see that
right here sine of negative theta that's
the negative that's the opposite of the
sine of theta so we have that there but
the cosine of negative theta is the same
thing as the cosine of theta
so these things are the same
so we're left with negative sine
theta
over cosine of theta
which is the same thing which is equal
to negative
tangent
theta
and so we see here if you make the angle
if you take the negative of the angle
you're going to get the negative of the
tangent and that's because the sine the
numerator
our definition of tangent change changes
signs but the denominator does the
denominator does not so tangent of
negative theta is the same thing as
negative tangent of theta
now what about
what about this point
right over here well over here relative
to theta when we're looking at pi minus
theta
so when we're looking at tangent of pi
minus theta
so tangent
of
pi
minus theta that's sine
of pi minus theta
over cosine
of pi minus theta and we already
established in the previous video
that sine of pi minus theta is equal to
sine of theta and we see that right over
here they have the exact same signs so
this is
equal to sine of theta well cosine of pi
minus theta well it's it's the opposite
of cosine of theta it's a negative of
cosine of theta so this is negative
cosine theta and so this once again is
going to be equal to the negative sine
over cosine or the negative tangent
of theta which makes sense this
ray should have the same slope as this
ray
as this ray right over here
and we see that slope we could view this
as negative tangent
negative tangent of theta and we see
just looking at we just see looking at
these two i guess if you if you take if
you combine the rays that these two
intersecting lines have the negative
slope of each other there are mirror
images across the x axis
and so we've just seen if you take an
angle and you add pi to the angle your
tangent won't change because you're
going to essentially be sitting on the
same line pi if you think in degrees
you're going 180 degrees around you're
going in the opposite direction but the
slope of your array has not changed so
tangent of theta is the same thing as
the tangent of theta plus pi
but if you take the negative of your
angle then you're going to take you're
going to get the negative of your
tangent or
or if you were to go go over here and if
you were to take pi minus your angle if
you were to take pi minus your angle
then you're also going to get the
negative of your tangent so hopefully
this makes you a little bit
this is very useful when you're trying
to kind of work through trigonometric
problems or try to find relationships or
even when we're trying to use our
identities or proof identities and
essentially what we've done here is we
have proven some identities but it's
really helpful to think about these
symmetries that we have within the unit
circle